good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
but I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the world's major problems
so to help you on your journey today's
message is fall-forward over to you
Denzel Washington
[Music]
I found that nothing in life is
worthwhile unless you take risks
nothing Nelson Mandela said there is no
passion to be found playing small and
settling for a life that's less than the
one you're capable of living now I'm
sure in your experiences in school and
applying to college and picking your
major and deciding what you want to do
with life I'm sure people have told you
to make sure you have something to fall
back on make sure you got something to
fall back on honey but I never
understood that concept having something
to fall back on
if I'm going to fall I don't want to
fall back on anything except my faith I
want to fall forward I figure at least
this way I'll see what I'm going to hit
fall forward this is what I mean Reggie
Jackson struck out 26 hundred times in
his career the most in the history of
baseball but you don't hear about the
strikeouts people remember the home runs
for Polie Thomas Edison conducted 1,000
failed experiments did you know that I
didn't know that
because the 1,000 and first was the
light bulb fall forward
every failed experiment is one step
closer to success so I love the concept
of falling forward and seeing failures
not as true failures but as opportunity
to learn and grow and get better I think
it also applies to how we see ourselves
in our daily lives and the decisions we
make and how hard we are in ourselves I
believe that you need to kick yourself
forward instead of
taking yourself down I once got after
the interview by the reporter would
saying how hard should you be on
yourself can you be too hard on yourself
and at first I was confused with a
question like too hard on yourself how
can you be too hard yourself no you
can't be too hard on yourself and after
going home and thinking about it I was
actually frustrated with my answer
because I'm so in on the heart of myself
forward and kicking myself forward that
the part that I miss is most people kick
themselves down most people are so hard
on themselves that then they don't take
any action that they tell themselves
they can't do something that they suck
and they'll never amount to anything and
they have no value and they should quit
and go off into something else well
people just kick themselves down or what
you want is the ability to kick yourself
forward to say this sucked I know I can
do better what I just created is not my
best work
here are the 20 areas that I need to
improve on and I'm going to go and work
on that right now to see the failure and
the negativity and the holes and what
you're making and use that as motivation
to go off and do better that's how I
default to I think it's how most
entrepreneurs will default to you kind
of have to if you just live in
negativity land of how much you suck and
how you're never going to get anywhere
you're just kicking yourself down it's
really hard to build a successful
business if you are that hard on
yourself and you never take any action
you're never going to get anywhere but
entrepreneurs who are hard on themselves
to keep themselves forward it can be
harder on themselves than anybody else
around them but in a positive way that
pushes them to action those are the
people who win so I encourage you to
think about you being hard on yourself
is it helping you are you just beating
yourself up or you're using it as
motivation and fuel to do a better job
so I'm going to make that the question
of the day question of the day do you
kick yourself down would you kick
yourself forward super curious leave the
comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to gene from Third Eye
brand gene thank you so much you're
picking up a copy of my book you're one
word and posting my picture on Instagram
I really really really appreciate it and
I hope you're enjoying the read thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever
your one word is much love and you'll
see you guys again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press Oh
and as you begin to challenge yourself
you discover some things about yourself
that you don't know right now the other
thing is you begin to look at yourself
look at your dreams it and and begin
begin to experiment and stepping in to
your greatness one of the things that's
very important whatever goals and dreams
that you have repeat after me please
make your move before you're ready their
price Pritchett is a great great
motivator and trainer said make your
move before you're ready we're
instructed in life to walk by faith and
not by sight until you want to really
begin to stretch yourself you want to
become a risk-taker you want to raise
the bar on yourself most people won't do
that see most people engage in low life
living low risk living this God said if
you're not willing to risk you cannot
grow and if you cannot grow you cannot
become your best and if you cannot
become your best you can't be happy and
if you can't be happy then what else is
there I like what Helen Keller said life
is short and unpredictable
eat the dessert first and so you want to
begin to take some chances you want to
begin to challenge yourself and they
could okay to feel and learn from your
failures don't allow fear of failure and
the Lord the attractiveness of playing
it safe in life to draw you in you can't
get out of life alive you've got to dot
I leave here the movies that I made
while I was making the fresh print so
with the fresh prints during the the
winter and then the the summers were bad
boys independent so many black you know
so it was like it really captured a time
so it's a it's very difficult I wouldn't
have it any other way I love being able
to make people smile and cheer you know
over that but I also am going to boldly
go to new creation you know even
something something like the decision
you know I had the two screenplays in
front of me for the Independence Day two
and
for Suicide Squad so I had to choose
between the two of those and even the
choice of going to Suicide Squad nothing
nothing about the qualities of the movie
but the choice of trying to go forward
versus clinging and climb backwards you
know so I do want to aggressively go
forward and do new things and create and
hopefully be able to stumble upon a new
heyday failure is a part of the learning
process right what's the risk of failure
what you'll be embarrassed or risk of
how do you distinguish failure from
learning in your whole life you know
failure implies that it stopped that the
game stops right if it's part of a
you're failing and then you learn then
that learning is part of the moving
forward right so that is what the
process is like fail learn move forward
and constantly do that because you're
cutting edge you're going where people
haven't been before in inventiveness
that's exciting